are working through shutdowns and
restrictions restaurants dealing with
another problem
staffing shortages kate houston went to
lotus of cyan which is having to close
another location
due to what is an ongoing issue guests
that walk up to lotus of siam on sahara
will be greeted by this temporary
closure sign
management says they're now looking to
fill nearly every position
that was the hardest decision we had to
make courtney barnett helps manage lotus
of siam and its small
staff it was manageable with 25 percent
manageable with
50 and then just
the succession of going to full open
capacity
has been harder barnett says this
staffing shortage is not for a lack of
trying
open interviews have been held three
days a week with jobs posted online
people did reply and say they were
interested but nobody
showed up barnett says local restaurants
are competing in a wage war with the
strip
it's hard to compete with the strip
prices
and so we're all just trying to put our
heads down
and get as much work done as we can but
it's been
really hard to find people to help out
lotus of siam is not alone
i've never seen anything like this mark
steele with the restaurant hospitality
institute is now partnering with
nonprofits to fast
track training i have my phone ringing
off the hook like crazy people looking
for
qualified candidates steele is hosting
job fairs to connect trainees with
restaurants
some are starting the very same day
steele says this won't be an overnight
fix
but can help take the pressure off of
local businesses i don't think that
their end in sight is very
very near sadly but we're just hoping to
bridge the gap
with these nonprofits and anyone who
wants to work kate houston
8 news now